i'm more into this uh pete davidson i
love this guy now he's dating kim
kardashian i [ __ ] love it no one on
my staff ever dates anyone famous but
like it's saturday night live like colin
jost got scarlett johansson he married
her i try with my guys when we had khloe
kardashian here you know she had the
paparazzi waiting for her and i said
chloe would be okay if jd walked out
with you and held your hand we could
start a rumor that jd is going out with
you and she goes sure jd walks out with
khloe kardashian there's about 25
photographers jd's holding her hand the
whole time
not one [ __ ] newspaper reported it
no pictures published
they looked nothing nothing published
even the press looked at jd went there's
no [ __ ] way not pop she even hugged
me she tried to sell it more she tried
to she hugged me too so and nothing like
like like literally while the guys are
clicking away
no did you see the latest jd from the
howard stern like we tried to get
something going
i remember jd one guy said to you are
you with the make-a-wish organization
they thought that she was doing
something nice
there were a bunch of people like
running around trying to get her
autograph or a picture and they were
just like looking at me like what
are you doing get out of the
way jd jd was invisible he was like the
invisible man he's holding hands with
khloe kardashian and she's hugging him
and nothing not one picture the next day
nothing not even a who is this with
chloe carter
who is this mystery man no they need
nothing exactly they knew exactly what
the deal was then i tried to set you up
with uh elliott spitzer's gal ashley
dupre but you blew that too i was hoping
you'd get famous from that but nothing i
i try with these guys you can't say i'm
not crazy
yeah i just i don't know what it was
about me that she wasn't attracted to
no and then remember i set up chris
wilding with andy cohen and chris
couldn't even get anything to go well
either
oh nothing
totally blew it
chris nice looking guy i thought he'd
close that deal easily i mean jd i know
you got your issues i don't know what
happened andy andy opened our date
saying this is not a date so
i didn't think uh there was much
opportunity there listen i tried with
robin too i hooked her up clarence
clemons the saxophone player from the e
street band she would have been the yoko
of the e street band
but it didn't work out it wasn't good
enough for her
to be at me somewhere right now and kind
of sit down and
go ahead man candle and oh
[Music]
all right let me know when you're gonna
do it
okay and i'll do it at the same time
[Music]
her face the face of an angel oh why
thank you
looking at me like are you gonna rescue
me or what are you
like right you had you had to see the
look
another question for this interview
joe frazier was in love with you i think
you could have been mrs joe frazier one
of the greatest boxers in the world she
turned to him down too i tried with her
serenaded her
he sure is all good he is so good
somebody
when somebody love you back
to be loved
and love in return is the only thing my
heart desires
to appreciate
the little things i do
oh you're the one that got me inspired
keep on lifting me look at me hi i
thought that was so good
yeah robin
a lot of fun with that guy
the day that his heart was broken
one day he walked into my little auntie
room that was outside of my studio and
there was a huge picture of muhammad ali
[Music]
[Laughter]
you've been courted by the best of the
best robin i could sing too i know you
can do that i won't think
to her
well since my baby left me
and i found a new place to dwell
in a lonely street heartbreaking
right now